les industriels tant que temps que
l'état cautionne je veux dire sont à
directement responsabilité on a tenté de
mettre en place des textes pour qu'ils
aient une responsabilité sociale des
multinationales à l'étranger ça n'a pas
abouti pour l'instant donc je dirais les
industriels jouent leur carte
industrielle points le problème est
complètement au niveau du gouvernement
qui est tu as la foi dans une mauvaise
stratégie
commercialement parlant est à la fois
qui entame complètement l'image qu'on
pouvait avoir à l'étranger d'un pays des
droits de l'homme d'un pays à au respect
du droit humanitaire
donc voila moi ce que je trouve
déplorable c'est qu'on est perdant sur
tous les tableaux
et pendant ce temps là on a mis plus de
deux ans pour faire un rapport sur sur
les exportations d'armes dont on pouvait
déjà écrire le tout scénario il y a deux
ans